hello and welcome to the lobby a very
special lobby live from penny arcade
expo in boston at all these people and
today's show Pete Hines from the deserts
over to tell us all about Wolfenstein
we've got a bunch of zoe quinn alexander
Bruce and my good friend Richard gallop
on the talk about doing the reasons why
they make games plus Peter for somebody
in the audience at somebody else to feel
like they could have worn a PlayStation
Vita and feel really bad but as i'm
meghan home but first of all i'm host on
you are joining us ever but my partner
in crime Chris waters Hayden very happy
to be joined by the dudes from capybara
games Nathan vela and chris petrosky
wonder if i get right that was really
nailed it the hardest part of this job
is seeing people's names on Twitter for
like four years and then [ __ ] up
their surnames realizing you never
actually said it to yourself in your
never know nathan is alive yeah be lying
so Nathan apart from being everyone's
favorite Canadian video game awards show
host you also are a frequent visitor to
our what's going on Mary commanders you
want this what for me can I have both of
them alright couple double Mike I'm
going to double down apart from that you
also create video games on come on our
show like every other week to talk about
them yeah the last time I saw you you
were handing me a beer after all this is
the best beer that I've ever had so yeah
word may make me feel extra bad for not
appear you should have had here's for us
actually that's okay you're here to show
up below which is playable on the show
floor yeah I'm playable first time ever
we announced it on stage at the
microsoft e3 press conference last year
and then kind of went dark while we were
making it and now PAX East is the
perfect place for us to kind of open it
up and let everyone play it you actually
we realized that we showed super time
force for the very first time in PAX
East now we're showing below for the
very first time at PAX East so basically
we're just here we're just going to keep
making games just to reveal at PAX East
that's right we got a staple like the
behemoth
yeah and there since the dawn of time
forever it's actually the packs model
left so yeah we're here to show we're
here to show below below is cappy's
roguelike inspired adventure game it's
it's all about you as a tiny character
in a rather large world and chris is
gonna dive right in and give her some
Giberson going you can you can start
playing man stop playing the video game
Oh am i playing now you're playing
people see me playing everyone's going
to take my skank there you go shut up
raise your hand and one of our lives
their audio Oh it'll be okay to begin
not yes here Danny all right I can
scream if he was okay your voice will
last 12 minutes saying we should turn on
my microphone this is how we roll man I
love it hello hello below go for it
there we go sorry so yeah below is is
our new game coming to steam and xbox
one we just announced the steam part of
that recently so very excited to get it
to our PC fans and and below is a game
where you arrive in an island we don't
show you any text we don't tell you why
you're there there's no real tutorials
we just let you go and the goal of the
game is to explore its to survive and
through those two you end up discovering
why you're there what the island is why
you're delving through the depths of the
island and and you get to do a heck of a
lot of really badass combat and it's
brutal you're going to die a hell of a
lot it seems to be a theme of games
lately that you're going to die a lot
but you're definitely going to die and
then the next version of you comes and
it's sequential you're not just
responding and restarting the game over
and over again you're actually another
wanderer showing up at the island after
the last one okay and the work that you
do the things that you achieve the stuff
that you find in one playthrough carries
over to the next one so if you pick up
an item and go a couple levels deeper
and then die drop that item is actually
on your corpse it's not going to just
magic
appear back where it was you actually
have to like go through and find your
corpses and you know through each life
progress further through the depths so
this is kind of I guess maybe a
spiritual successor to source 3
obviously Chris working on that and did
both we do the musical or not and then
the art style is kind of similar enough
is this a very different gameplay
experience to what support oh yeah
definitely I mean stylistically I think
it's there's similarities we work
definitely focusing on a very specific
kind of mood and a specific sort pace
but then once you get into sort of the
nitty-gritty of the of the game it's a
complete game I mean it's it's really
very much about you know learning how to
become good at the combat learning how
to understand like what's going on in
the environment so in terms of like just
pure pure gameplay it has a much denser
richer sort of experience than sorcery I
guess in the more traditional gaming
sort of sense and you guys set the room
right from the start here I've got to
play this on the show floor down at the
Double Fine booth and it starts off with
that look really long climb up the wall
and then you know you're then you're
descending here and what struck me is
the size of the character relative to
the rest of the screen I was trying to
figure the last game that I played where
there's such a discrepancy between you
know that you guys are using all of this
space and being so small what what how
is that it was sort of the inspiration
for that aesthetic when you guys trying
to make me feel like here because i feel
kind of lonely we're trying to make you
feel like a completely fragile and
insignificant be that's very sweet of
you yeah and it's you're welcome for
from the very beginning of the very
first time the chris even pitched us the
concept at the studio the idea was to
create this like sense of scale that
you're small you're weak you're one
mistake away from dying it basically
every turn and in order to do that we
really wanted to play that up with most
of the dungeons in the game which are
entirely procedurally generated our
single screens so you have a very clear
sense of scale
it's very clear that you're small and
the world is much larger but you also
know where you can explore and because
it's inspired by roguelikes there are
certain things like the fact that is
procedurally generated and that death is
permanent the way that health works into
the game is that you take damage and
even the smallest amount of damage will
start you bleeding and if you don't deal
with the fact that you're bleeding like
a normal human you will eventually agree
to death so a little little
insignificant enemy not dealt with
correctly can't kill you if you don't
know what you're doing and then all are
like making hard games we do we this
game is meant to be challenging and it's
we love the wheel of the audience of
hard games when we love hard games
ourselves whether it's super time force
or below both of those games are meant
to be challenging games that are going
that you learned through do it you learn
through playing you learn through
experiencing the world and then learning
about it and coming back the next time
and may be dying on a spike trap and
just die you did die a lot it's amazing
i sleep done how many times have you
done this demo like a thousand times I
played that one up for the crab yeah
that was but he was ham and asad coming
from miles away but you as you go
through you will learn like ok these
things are dangerous and a lot of cases
you're learning by poking around yes
trying to like search your way through
it and you know maybe that's going to
kill you but the next time you come in
the next wonder that arrives they know
better how difficult is it to demo a
game like this where not only is it like
the mood is so like intimate but then
also the lack of information that you
give it to the player at one of these
games where you kind of just have to
learn like feel almost have difficulty
doing are you two playing on schedule
all right I that environment we've been
really really choked on the fact that
people die again right we go for a
record that's that's our game right
there in a nutshell you've been
experienced players are going to get
knocked on their butts now thank you
guys I'm just nervous I'm nervous I've
never played it from the crab hard games
government planes been playing on rock
shows
if you've got any questions in fact I
put your hand up oh my god yeah do it
over here you got a mic over there a guy
folks get that you too Mike Chris will
die like five times before the might
guess you don't worry about that he's
focused now look at him this that is the
Danai of the tiger what is this thing
gonna hit him card yes they're like a
concept of bosses within this like games
like rogue legacy have bosses that are
like preconceived will there be like
some sort of randomness of the bosses if
there are some there's a there's a big
component to the game that that we're
not talking about just yet but it does
sort of encapsulate the boss sort of
concept so kind of roundabout answer
yeah yes with a question mark and I die
? sorry I didn't know if you go you're
able to talk about it and like you know
if variety of like Shannon Colossus and
dark souls so that's the last time the
other thank you we're more we're friends
now awesome thanks very much great shirt
as well add you have any other questions
over there I can't see yet dude right
there wearing the plaid why am I saying
that every time I'm wearing plaid and I
really enjoy the music a lot um what
kind of the inspiration for where that
came from well the Jim Guthrie is the
guy making the music so we work with him
previously on sword and sorcery and so
such a great experience that right after
that project was done we were just like
you know we knew we want we wanted to
make below right after that project and
we just basically wanted to work
together again and so the tone oh look
at this one hahaha he oh he oh yeah yeah
go no I got killed because I wreck you
literally haha that one was not my
father stole a valium extreme picture I
mean we basically got captured in gym
and locked him in a room until yeah
below with us he's for those of us who
grew up in Ontario Jim's actually kind
of an indie rock legend he's his music
was like we were listening to it when we
were in university together
and being able to work with someone who
can do sorcery and then do the
soundtrack for indie game the movie and
then do a soundtrack for other
documentaries and then also you know how
Chris sitting in his studio jamming on
the game to make sure that the game has
the right vibe in the right tone and
that the music works well with what
we're trying to do kind of the space and
with even like making the player maybe
feel a little more lonely in certain
cases or making them feel like maybe
there's something bigger coming up but
just working with someone who can do
that is a gym I use magic were you he's
in then into like doing soundtracks for
video game stuff people like a lot of
people myself would have assumed that's
how we like that was what he was doing I
have no idea Jim Joyce like doing a
whole bunch of amazing indie rock and
then he met Craig d adams from super
brothers and they started doing a couple
little projects together that they did a
like a video called children of the
clone which was Craig's animations to
like Jim started playing around with the
PlayStation music maker product early on
so he made all these like little fun
weepy bloopy gym sounds that these
nudists and track for VIP ribbon is that
we just saying I know but it's you know
it's got that kind of crazy weird Jim
vibe through a PlayStation music program
and then that was sort of one of the
inspirations for for the music style of
sorcery it sort of was like building on
this thing I medium that Jim was started
doing in his basement on his own it's a
big a big part of all of our games and
this game especially is we were trying
to make a game that's you know got all
really you know deep gameplay but we're
also trying to make it aesthetically
focused and the visuals in the audio are
essential to the experience they're not
just something that kind of America's
you need to have some graphics it's a
lot of the game play in the game is
built around the visual style and around
us missoula being able to like build a
game around great art and around great
sound makes it a lot easier for us to
crack the exact type of experience that
they have a craft and hopefully the
exact experience that players over they
want to dive into and poke around in and
explore so this come into xbox one and
pc do you have any other idea of when
better better players we're gonna get in
2014 I hope so I remember not to not
answer never yeah then I hope so too we
have we've learned not to go too far
ahead of ourselves you guys take your
time as well we do we really believe
that the best thing that developers can
have is a chance to like spend time with
their projects and we really kind of use
the local bread reference where it needs
time to prove and then it needs time in
the oven and it needs to be golden brown
before we're going to take it out and we
don't think the worst thing that we can
do is the studio is hand unfinished work
to people who are going to pay money for
ourselves we really wanted we want to be
able to look people in the face and tell
them that we think it's great and not be
lying we want to make sure that the
stuff that we put out is what we want to
put out and sometimes that means the
games take a little longer and hopefully
we can do our best to get this one in
people's hands as soon as possible we're
going to be now that it's out there in
the open we've been super quiet about it
now thats on the open we're going to try
to show as much as we can about the game
and try to you know get as many people
seeing as much as we can soon so stay
tuned folks I'm win a super time force a
super time horse is out very soon
end of May early June is what we're
looking at this it's in testing and
certification right now so we're really
excited that's that's a it's the first
time that we really like been able to
look sit back and say holy crap we just
made a giant crazy platformer with time
travel so yeah it scared a lot of fun
it's going to be a heck of a year first
yeah yeah so that's gettin busy yeah
everybody who's been following super
time for so get a chance to play it real
soon on 360 n on xbox one is more
excellent a good pitch man I like it I I
know my I know my beats and I know how
to hit those marks well last question
are you a ghost the IGF Awards accurate
i use doc now are you in are you the new
Andy shots I don't have to do projects
to not pull off a pink shirt like Andy
shell of a pink shirt um I think he can
I have never tried actually well
Alexander Bruce is here maybe he could
do it he rocks a picture pretty good
Alexander can do everything better than
everyone so that's not a fair comparison
I don't think they said I would love to
do it again if they'll have me I was a
lot of fun hand and awards to my friends
and people that I believed really
deserved it and also they're telling
some jokes and having some fun I'm
drinking some beers yes indeed same
again next year Nathan Chris thank you
so much for coming on random applause
these four below
this is the part of the show where we
usually play a video people can't see
everyone run off the stage but instead
we're just gonna we're just going to
edit that bit out for the Tuesday show
so if you have a car sir any thanks
everyone out yeah and you guys can
totally play that like that demo is
literally right down at Double Fine's
booth in any big like double fine and
happy I'm fighting haha it's called the
booth of love booth of love tim schafer
called it the booth of love so that's
its official name I said please combine
play we've bumped into that yes ready
and then I'm as if by magic a Pete Hines
appears i'm going to use this moment to
check on the FA Cup semi-final because
arsenal are playing Wigan oh we just got
it we just equalized parameter soccer
yeah 11 come for your video games stay
for the soccer results 86 minutes all
right god damn it such a butt here Pete
don't touch Pete Hines but it was a
light Gray's oh really it's all right we
go back we go back sir Pete Hines oh
yeah that's the soft works nice to see
you again sir she use her you're here
for her that's my guy i made the hell
right yeah we put it in the shot and
then it was too heavy to bring yours
let's go photograph instead Wolfenstein
the new order yeah playable on the show
floor absolutely you guys have a big old
q very long when I run but it's worth it
and what give us the pitch for folks who
have not seen much of Wolfenstein um
hopefully everybody knows Wolfenstein it
basically invented first-person shooters
as a thing this is a game that is sort
of sticks with the canon of Wolfenstein
but it's it's been made by ice and guys
called machine games and a large group
of whom were used to do used to be at a
different developer and made games like
chronicles of riddick and the darkness
and are known for taking action and
combining in things like story and
character and trying to have it be a bit
more than just a one-note thing and they
really were interested in
taking Wolfenstein and saying look we
wanted to kind of do a reboot like not
not starting over from the beginning but
pushing it forward in doing something
else with it and adding a lot to it like
BJ doesn't mean anything to anybody yes
just he's just the guy holding the gun
that you're pulling the trigger on so we
want to we want to explore like what is
he like and and they really like this
alternate universe idea of you start the
game in World War two BJ goes into a
coma it takes some shrapnel in the head
goes into a coma 14 years later he wakes
up to find the Nazis won the war and
rule the world don't you hate it when
that happened I it's a nightmare and and
so it's really you and him and going
through this sort of man out of time
story where you're figuring out what
would the world be like in the 1960s if
the Nazis ruled everything he's got to
find the resistance and start to fight
back because that's you know that's all
he knows it it's one of those things
where he's sort of at first blush he's
just like a big headed guy who likes to
shoot Nazis but actually his whole thing
is like he just wants to go home he just
wants to go home and leave a normal life
and the only way to do that is to kill
all the Nazis and so it's like that
that's kind of what he does and he's
very good at it but ultimately he just
wants you know a wife and kids in a
white picket fence and so it's it's a I
think it's a really well done thing I
think hopefully you guys have seen some
of the trailers we just we just put one
out last week and whose idea was it to
have a referee shooting soccer was it
actually her idea like I mean look 14
years in Bethesda i finally got soccer
under one of our trailers yeah but we
like the idea of playing with the the
alternate reality and it looked not
Caesar probably the easel easily
hateable no need context like what's
their motivation why why don't I like
them like Oh Nazis got it bullethead
let's go have you guys seen the most
recent trailer the one with the soccer
rough getting blasted no oh you're
missing out it's pretty bad running in
the booth come by and see it in the
booth because it has one of my favorite
things about this game and it's the
villains like you say Nazis you don't
need a reason to hate them but you guys
are really going out of your way to give
us a lot of specific people to hate
because they are crazy and creepy and
this dude general death's-head in the
demo like he moves a little like Gollum
and he has this like skeletal like
literally turn
round is like started yeah just
creepy-looking and not cool he's got
he's got some great he's got some great
line from the trailer I love like
general death's-head I don't like it I'm
a happy man like and he basically is
just performing awful human experiments
so um yeah I mean it goes back to the
question before about machine games and
what are they trying to do like it's
about story and character for them like
yes you could just make it about generic
Nazis but it's a lot more fun when you
get to know some of them and appreciate
like you hate them on a whole different
level you don't want them to die you
like a guy badly that's a weird kind of
it's like interesting because wolf 3d no
one was playing for the story no more
like even return to castle but like any
one of these games they're just they
were blaster shooter games yep and like
how how do you guys try and have like
interesting characters that way don't
need on a story too much but also have
to like ridiculous gone warfare is the
last half of that trailer basically was
just like all these ridiculous gone yeah
like double dual wielding double
automatic shotguns and like these crazy
Nazi weapons that you get your hands on
where you can like melt for dudes at
once it's it's that balance where they
wanted to sort of push the idea of the
shooter mechanic and make it fun and by
the way it's not just a shooter so they
you know they've layered in all this
stuff where you can play it as a more
stealthy game in the game plays
differently like you can run into a room
guns blazing and take everybody out or
you can also move through and find
secret passages and get behind the enemy
and take out the commander so he can't
call in reinforcements there's a whole
perk system to the games are doing stuff
like this where your stomach not see
stats test oven it's kind of a nurses in
the head but you start to unlock special
abilities the more you do this then you
learn new ways to do stealth takedowns
where instead of having to sneak up on
them you can throw a knife from a
distance and take down a guy down the
hallway instead of trying to make them
and there's different ones for that for
you know whether you want to be more
like demolition like explosion focused
or how you use your gun so it does allow
some variety it's not just a one-note
linear thing and I think again the
character and story stuff just adds to
that the guys that you're you're
fighting alongside the guys that you're
shooting you know at all it all fits
together to make it
full experience you can see here some of
the deformable terrain stuff where
you're blasting away with this day
euphemism for a dude getting his head
blown to bits if there were mobile sorry
i was referring to the column but the
head is part of the deform terrain but
yeah you know setting it in an
environment where you feel sort of
powerful and cool and kick an ass
kicking ass is still fun I'm going to
throw it out to the audience for a
second for some questions I would ask
one more in the meantime though abso
this is single player only seeing that
there is an association with
first-person shooters and especially
games that of any sort of like hot
history with its software of multiplayer
like how are you guys trying to you know
get over perceptions audience I think
for a lot of other publishers that would
probably be a trickier question to
answer but Bethesda stands defiantly in
support of single-player stuff fallout 3
Skyrim dishonored evil within
Wolfenstein we believe if multiplayer
fits and it's part of what you're trying
to create you should absolutely do it
but if it's not for God's sake leave it
out stop shoehorning multiplayer in this
stuff that has no business being there
and ultimately machinegames knows
machine games no single player they and
this is the kind of game they wanted to
create and so we just never really had a
conversation about multiplayers like all
right if that's not what you're making
then let's just make this the best thing
we can and that's what we're doing I and
I think there's plenty of folks who
still are enjoy and appreciate you know
a nice good robust last of us had a
player from but I'd never played it once
but that's the best money I spent last
year just playing that single player
experience and so I think this can be a
game in that vein cool I got any
questions out there could we maybe get
over this side we got the middle last
time yeah you're gonna make you run
dudes at the back I see you then I
saying hands wave them furiously we get
a microphone do we have the mic art
breed Oh stand up there all this was
standing microphone oh yeah you just do
that
a well-oiled machine haven't you been to
pax before I there wasn't standing
microphone earlier these big lights are
in my face no um we got all out there
all right cool cool potato mash him
first question do it yeah that looks
like a potato masher is this using its
own game engine or is there a shared
game anchoring with any bethesda or it
it's using a modified version of in tech
five so they took the existing in tech
stuff and did a whole bunch of stuff to
it because they wanted to do more things
with not some dynamic lighting and not
see texturing and things that it didn't
support is this getting released in
germany it is but in Germany there they
have a thing about Nazis out there are a
little little touchy don't know if you
know and so it they're called the regime
in Wolfenstein in Germany and it's
actually I'm pretty sure this is the
first Wolfenstein game that will ever be
released in germany but it's completely
stripped of all the constitutionally yes
and content I thought Return to Castle
Wolfenstein was released it might've
been named it they said it was like a
germ warfare game it was or something
yeah but yeah no it'll be released there
but it's a it's about a random meetup
group of bad guys the baddies yeah they
know what it really is though I'm just
hoping to be Aryan featured and yeah and
I've German accent gross what is going
on go for it gross it's a question
that's des it's a single-player only
game what are some of the things that
you're going to have us keep coming back
for besides maybe the multiple scale
trees or the weapons or the difficulty
sure it's a good question replayability
obviously is it is an important thing
extending what you're getting for your
money is something we're very well aware
of there's a couple of different things
we're doing one is a mode we're not
actually talking about yet although I'm
lobbying for us to talk about it soon
but there are there's a collectible
aspect in the game and once you play any
particular chapter you can go back and
replay it if you want to find the
collectibles you missed but if you find
all the collectibles you unlock this
cool new mode and when I actually
convince everybody to start talking
about it you'd be like that is super
cool and I want to find all the
collectibles just to try that mode
cuz it's not just a hey the game got
harder you played it earlier on the uber
mode and it's pretty yeah it's pretty
difficulty is not a thing we need more
of at this point we wanted to do
something different but it was good like
I've started on the fourth of five
difficulty levels and I felt like I was
moving along like all right you know I
have to use cover here but I felt
comfortable but I didn't want to feel
comfortable so I kicked it up and then I
done got you're asking me to and doing a
lot of time but I was you know
especially this scene when you you know
this stabbing happens that it's
wonderful but then like there's so many
other guys there that you have to try to
stab this is the point where bj bj is
waking up from his coma yeah the Nazis
are basically killing everybody in this
island where he's being been kept and
taken care of and he's got to he's right
now he's basically fighting his way
through and trying to get back to anya
who is the woman who's been taking care
of him audia it's it's not easy doing
this section as stealthily as you can
when you play the game cuz once it gets
loud or just do that there's so many of
them really murder every shop n dice is
also highly effective yeah that's
disgusting add today more questions
lining up to the microphone in their Pro
go ahead sir all right do it you just
jump and say your question again come on
dude no oh man this was like fitting the
cannon with Wolfenstein um but like I
can kind of see that is going for a more
futuristic styling where the last
Wolfenstein game kind of like went crazy
with like the whole like mystical stuff
I can't disowning that activision one
yeah so so the question if you didn't
hear it was basically the last one did
more of this mysticism thing this one is
more focused on tech we sort of went
like this with the mysticism stuff and
just said look like the reason the Nazis
won the war is because they have this
amazing technology and that technology
is super advanced and allow them to win
the war in ways they couldn't have
otherwise so there's no like moving
between planes of existence or stuff low
it's just it's a more grounded realistic
thing it's a it's grittier look this is
for me like I look at this as like the
dark night we
would of Wolfenstein where it's like
it's it's a little grittier it's trying
to be a little bit more grounded and and
I think that that's a part of an
important part of it and as you go along
you start to figure out about the
technology that becomes an important
part for the resistance like where they
get this stuff can I have some too
because I would love to use it against
them that kind of thing right Thanks
that's a great question I just in the
meantime it's ended 0-0 that's they'll
all to any UK people in the arsenal game
so replay fun go for it um I just wanna
know uh how hard was it to like take a
character like BJ blaskowitz who's like
he pretty much has no emotions in the
first couple games in it like in all of
them actually it's got out of the face
he goes oh yeah that's it oh how hard is
it to like humanize a character like
that where everybody's just like I'm a
guy I go around and I murder everybody
and that's my job it does it's very good
it's a very good question actually I
wish we had it it's not in the mural but
we said gamespot might have it up we I
think one point we did a little side by
side comparison of obj and new BJ
graphics compare words like the 16 pixel
you know it's like just in case you've
forgotten BJ his head is about this big
and this is what he looked like and this
is how he looks at nextgen as far as a
personality that's a that's a tricky
line to walk because whenever you start
to characterize the person you're
playing it might not be the way you
envisioned yourself like we're starting
to to put more context to it as opposed
to letting you fill it in yourself like
it's an important thing we do is Skyrim
for example like you don't have a voice
like you you are who you ever you want
to be we're not we're not saying stuff
on your behalf but in Wolfenstein I
think the you know yen's and his team at
machine games Tommy and some of the
other guys in writing the dialogue and
so forth had a very specific balance
they were trying to fit where it's it's
one of those things I really think you
have to play the game to appreciate
because I think you can see some of this
stuff out of context like he's not he's
not averse to one-liners like goofy
eighties movie action one-liners but he
has this interesting thing like where he
never uses contractions like he's and
like he he
speaks in sort of military talk very
effectively and then you also hear some
of his inner monologue stuff where he's
thinking stuff that just doesn't sound
like something that he would he wouldn't
necessarily say but like just like a
[ __ ] hate Nazis but that's how people
are like that's like like sometimes you
know what you say outside is things like
I just [ __ ] hate Nazis but what he's
thinking inside is so much deeper and
more poetic than that and we know that's
inside of you you're given to any a lot
of credit right that's actually all
that's in here and the depth of my Nazi
hey I don't know gonna fight it as you
play the game you kind of start to
appreciate a little bit like like where
he's coming from and what his motivation
is and how he thinks about stuff but
then he still has his funny little
one-liners like I'm coming for you you
[ __ ] Nazi base man and like you know
21 he says it like that and then it's
funny when he when you hear the internal
stuff like he I think he hits a good
tone it's it's really hard to do that
stuff and hit a hundred percent of your
audience somebody's gonna have an issue
with something but I personally like I
love it like every time I play the game
he still makes me laugh I find his
dialogue stuff really funny still so
hopefully you guys will enjoy it as well
this is one of those games that if I get
a chance to play it it's like you know a
bunch of people sitting around with
headsets on and I'm like cackling or
like talking [ __ ] to the enemies or
whatnot and I feel like I'm the only one
making a lot of noise in that just that
a silent room and you guys are watching
and just like we are just like crazy
outbursts we're recording it cuz we go
back and watch those later and it was
actually you who said I [ __ ] hate you
you not see space Nazi [ __ ] I can I
couldn't I can't write that kind of
poetry man I mean if I did awesome sorry
we don't have any time for any more
questions we gotta got the next group on
actually could you be super quick I feel
bad for you
I appreciate that the level of beer are
we gonna be able to rub our faces up
against you definitely lots of secret
quarters there's actually one in the
b-roll a little while ago with DES heads
photos but yeah secret passages and and
finding nooks and crannies and stuff is
all these these guys are huge wolf fans
this was a franchise that made them want
to make games so if you're a wolf fan
you will find lots of little oh ma jizz
and easter eggs in here and rub your
face up against the way you probably
don't have to smear yourself all the way
down no it's a it's slightly more
sophisticated than that now last
question are the portraits of Hitler and
every room there are not okay what you
to Hitler's there one and how many
portraits of Hitler or in your woman
side looking back to you okay yes I
haven't really talked about the Big H
guy been coy about it I like ya h-dog we
don't talk about hdl-c happy times does
the thank you so much for coming on
really appreciate it friend of applause
mr. Pete Hines
let's get you Joker's up here all right
Chris you're gonna go sort at the duel I
believe oh yeah I'm gonna get the duel
set up over here during the next segment
I'll I'll I'll pick some people get them
over here will will hype it up in just a
second so if you guys want to win a
playstation vita or if you want to
almost win a Playstation v yeah that's
an option 2i x I don't know how I'm
gonna do it i'll just come grab your son
who victory are you talking about a
video game no victory no it's victory
movie victory sylvester stallone and his
stock soccer team against nazi you
kidding me love it right okay yeah Thank
at rich Calif everybody everyone here
know rich girl needs
a man who needs no it is good and weird
to be back yeah it's weird to have you
here it's really gonna bring it over
here kind of your fault I'm sitting in
this chair so to want me to tell the
story you want to tell us you go from so
for people who don't know Alexander Zoe
probably don't know Alexander Bruce
everyone in romaji chamber and zoe quinn
the most popular person on the internet
so the story is once upon a time I used
to sit in this chair my bicester well
that share that guy was my boss these
guys were I was part of their crew I got
Chris his job yeah he went to college
with my wife I resume to rich any time
of posting was on games might rejoice
and after us a seven-year absence I
think you guys have finally maybe gotten
here okay okay you guys is awesome this
I never would imagine that you guys
would get this is you have a gorgeous
set you have great shows you have great
rapport with a gorgeous photograph upset
yeah I've seen the set though my desk
was behind that portrait yeah we have to
rip out the old on the spot thing I'm
sorry but where is it do it I don't know
it's probably Giancarlo zoms everything
else you're probably wondering why I
assembled this motley crew of random
game developers and I had interesting
chats with you guys at GDC and whenever
we talk it's always great to pick your
brain about the reasons why you're doing
what you're doing based on like your
personal lives so I had an interesting
chat with you Alex about you release the
antechamber you've been working on it
for 12 decades eventually got it out and
now are you out of love with indeed do
you want to go into mainstream game
development or was this all just like a
reason to get out of Australia and I
mean that in like I know you want to get
out of Australia it's complicated i mean
I don't even know if I want to get out
of side of Australia now you know I
blank testing the waters in a whole lot
of different ways I didn't get into
making antechamber because i was like i
love you know indie games i have to be
an independent the vet you know game
developer i was playing games all of my
life i was starting to get a bit over
what a lot of mainstream things were
doing sorry Bethesda who was just on I
was I need to get a bit over things and
so I went into universe
you know what i was doing gave myself a
lot of options fell into game
development fell into independent game
development and just had to spend
several years you know working on that
because everything was all really
circumstantial and after that process
was finished I didn't really know what
to do with myself and it's a bit
complicated you know emotions are
complicated but you know I just took
some time to step away from things think
about you know what I want to be doing
moving forwards so I'm still trying to
figure that out because you've been sort
of enjoying your time after antechamber
doing a lot of sort of touring coming to
events like this even though you're not
necessarily showing anything off like
what is it about any developments that
may be pushing you away or is it just
you've created things you want to do
with our intent but that can't be done
with that are you sick of it it's not
really things about independent
development about pushing me away it's
that I spent basically 26 years only
caring about work like my whole world
was just about work I made this game
things ran you know great and you know
the process was just so rough on me
emotionally that I was like I've had
this big success and now I don't know
what to do with myself and you know I'm
trying to people very adverse to change
yeah you move house you start a job you
lose a job it's difficult to deal with I
basically had to say all right 26 years
was one set of problems now absolutely
none of that matters here's a completely
new set of problems that you have to
deal with go yeah and that's and that's
quite difficult and so some of me
wanting to step away was just getting
away from that a bit writing ago some
other things speaking of emotion Zoe
obviously working on it's not okay Cupid
most people would know you from
depression quest which you created last
year and I didn't get to go but I heard
your panel Patrick yesterday was anyone
here at that one
what is it about because your work
especially over the past year has
basically it's been so maybe not
detrimental but it's impacted your
personal life so much what is it about
making games that why are you still
doing this if it's so negatively
affecting you and so many other to come
ways why am I still doing this I mean
honestly I still feel like I came from
all these different places and
creativity before ending up in games and
it's like the one thing that's been able
to hold my attention for this on being
able to combine all these different
things into one really cohesive specific
statement is I don't know another way to
do that and beyond that I feel like it's
just such a powerful medium in such an
exciting time to be here there's so many
different things happening and there's
like you can have real impact as an
indie game developer right now maybe
what happens in the future like being
able to come to things like this and
talk to people and talk to people who
maybe didn't know that they could be a
game developer yet and just need to hear
somebody tell them that they can do it
right being able to do that is such an
amazing thing and I am not sure what I
could what is more valuable than that
that I can be doing with my time and
with the amount of visibility that I
have suddenly out of nowhere yeah I mean
I've only I've only really been doing
this for two years to but I've loved
video games but like my entire life I'm
actually working on a weird silly thing
that a sort of decompress instead of
focusing on sun okcupid is it a reality
TV show but indeed no um have you seen
them to be the room yes I may be talking
with one of the cast members about doing
an F mvgame is it tommy was oh I don't
want to some of those because I want it
don't it ok but I I sort of want to be
able to do something goofy and
ridiculous and especially cuz like it's
an indie rite of passage to like be with
a nostalgic game of your childhood but
my first my first console was a 3d oh
okay my first console game was night
trap so it's my turn the video games
industry is tearing you apart lisa
herron mia but I got it so when you look
at these two young whippersnappers and
you as an elderly man you have more gray
hair than me my favor yeah p but not on
my I Bravo
well that happened I was like 12 hours
going it was the Horcrux that what it
was yep and so when I you know they're
young successful enjoying it in the
creative you know part of their life
you're jaded and tired I'm not jaded I'm
just rot Roo trying to rise on you right
now all right go ahead but you've got
like you've got a family you've got a
kid like how much does that influence
the type of work that you do we went
from the price into development you
obviously had you know 20 30 HR damn
that was must have been really traumatic
and then you had summer camp yes how
much of what you do creatively is
impacted by your your responsibilities
as a all of it right now and not only
impacts what I do creating but also how
I treat my co-workers so right now I'm
executive producer at disruptor beam we
have a game of thrones game game thrones
ascent will you announce our new game is
weak Star Trek timelines very exciting
stuff good pitch thank you I have to say
otherwise anyone let me come here no but
basically so I have a wife have a kid
that's why we moved back to the east
coast with so my wife go to law school
and pursue her career the chair was
starting to fall apart at gamespot so I
know and now that I have that and now
that I'm in a position in my career
where I help determine how other people
should be spending their time at work
like I know I want to spend I love my
job and I do my gel whole time but also
I love my son and I love my wife on us
seen as much as possible so I am in a
position to make sure that I get to do
that but then I also ensure that all my
co-workers to get to do that as well
like so I'm 35 now and from 22 to 32 it
was I was probably felt like i was
working 12-hour days is that fair Ryan
we were doing some of that yeah 60 yeah
but and that was awesome because I loved
it because that's all I wanted to do but
now it's like hey you know what's really
nice hammocks and if I want to spend
time in that hammock I can but I also
want to make sure that I want to work
surround we can also get some good
hammock time and also make a great game
like even though the scent do you think
that's why there's the the tends not to
be obviously those John Baum guys are
weird but the tends not to be that many
older game journalists like Jeff is
going to be doing that his entire life
right yeah like you're so
Brian ekberg like so my big gay why
would I game journalist anymore is
because because if I had to move
geographically and would you still be
doing it uh maybe it's it's so much more
fun to make something yourself than to
talk about someone else's stuff like
there's definitely some joy out of
making quote it's true like making the
show is awesome but like and having
those shows like we got to make a
cartoon actually based on my trap that
you should watch like that it's called
time trotters it's amazing excellent so
but making that show was more fun than
doing anybody's like you get to meet all
kinds of great people here and you get
to get to like it taste that creativity
but like for every person who's on a
couch from a studio there's another
there's hundreds more people they're
just as talented and just as awesome
like making some small part of the game
and to be able to be around those people
all the time and be able to just help
them do their job it's just it's awesome
also it's really nice having a deadline
that isn't today right like what are we
doing today okay what does it do all
right today all right good all right now
it's Tuesday what's up through it again
that's what the schedule is a king
swapping videos like wait we have months
or years we have years so I all the
stuff we can do yeah so you you work in
big teams alexander you were essentially
working on your own for that long period
of time that's the story do you feel
even just even in your own space you
were like i was working last later they
did have other people like in austin and
in the Netherlands but i did most of it
you so do you feel like if you were to
do another project whatever that may be
in games are not that you'd prefer to do
it with other people was that did that
take a toll it definitely took a toll I
mean like the circumstances that I mean
now very different to what I was going
through when I was making antechamber
and I mean like I know a hell of a lot
more talented people now than I did Ben
and so if I was starting up a new
project it would be much easier to get
people on board with with my ideas and
it was when I was just some random
student trying to convince other
students why they should work with me
instead of going drink beer yeah I'm and
Zoey you you tend to work on really
small projects that take like a couple
of months you kind of work on them get
the mayor working then get them out
you've got a long list of games that are
an avail
it's not something you like doing more
so like stuff that you could kind of
spend a couple of months on rather than
spending like your general like two or
three years development well it's tricky
I've been working on so I take you but
for two years actually and it's like oh
really yeah on and off yeah depression I
wasn't i expected five people to play a
depression quest for people think I was
insane and one person would be like okay
so that was totally not something I
expected at all I do like shorter dev
cycles because I especially because I'm
so new at this I learned things really
quickly like I'm still figuring out when
my voices and I'm so ridiculously burnt
out yeah like after two years and which
is one of the reasons I'm taking a step
away and doing something less serious
for a little while that's why you're
working on a new game yeah or that it's
it's just it's I'm also worried about
getting into that trap or you just keep
making new things in my ashley i'm
finishing with it um so I do kind of
want to shift into something where I'm
at least working with other people
partially to make sure a I don't get
designer itís and do that constantly and
be because it's really kind of miserable
working alone in the way that I have
them I need someone to because you like
King tunnel focus really hard and like
you sort of like are chasing your auntie
LAN changing things that don't need to
be changed and it's good to have someone
ought to be like you're being stupid
stop doing that so I'm hopefully going
to start doing different stuff in terms
of that awesome oh yeah I think the
sooner that you you can again be
recognized for the games and because
you've got an interesting alternative
persona now or like responsibility with
depression quest that sort of does that
get too much maybe sometimes where you
become this kind of voice for this
community it's it's definitely a lot
more than I ever anticipated like again
I thought no one would play it and as I
feel like there is sort of i do have
responsibility take it very seriously
i'm working through backlogs of months
of emails of people that have reached
out because it's i know it's how hard it
is to reach out to somebody and when
somebody tell it starts off an email if
I've never told anybody this before I
feel like that can't be responded to a
silence yeah and or and I know that I'm
probably running myself ragged doing
that but it's
really important to me so it's worth it
and yeah it's like I feel so so bad
sometimes too because people come to be
looking for answers it's like I'm not a
therapist I'm just a game developer but
yeah let's let's talk and I mean it's
just it's such a weird thing I never I
never thought be in any sort of position
to do this especially because I mean
video game yeah but much respect for
doing it in for tackling it and actually
responding to those emails because a lot
of other people who can do it and before
I let you guys go I want to ask because
this is packed and because you are all
involved in game development and so many
of you champion other games and what is
the one game on the show Florida you
think stands out Alexander first of all
mushroom 11 obviously you guys saw me at
the booth and lake if I forced you to
play that game and I'm forcing everyone
to it working because it's amazing and
you should all go play that game you
should work in PR and get rich i'll pick
tower of guns okay yeah yeah made by a
good friend of mine for 38 studios joe
mirabelle oh he's an environment artist
who made this rogue like basically a
tribute to doom first-person shooter
that if you like such things you should
play it it's on the floor there's a lot
of wrongs and guns lots of bullets lots
of money hops yeah straight circle
strafing yeah old are you just like will
consign except without the Nazis exact
I'm Zoe what do you think I'm gonna be
horrific Lee biased and go with framed
because it's doing a lot of interesting
stuff with nonlinear storytelling and
it's I also a major SAP foreign war
stories and it's got a really beautiful
art style i'm curious to see what that
ends up being at the end awesome rich
gallop alexander Bruce is zoe quinn
thank you so much for going on
you guys stay there for a minute I
believe something's gonna win a
PlayStation Vita before we get kicked
out of here let's get ready to do so
we're playing Star Wars even just the
tip yeah is your microphone your might
is this wrong I talk really loudly oh
there we go there we go ah first person
from this area to put up two hands gets
to play it was you he beat you had your
hand up first but he went to first I was
so close is that when see all right
and over here hold up exactly three
fingers this guy right here okay Oh the
game is star wall just the tip in the
year 20xx narwhals have ascended into
space faring life-forms whose only goal
is to jab each other in the hearts with
their pointy tusks we're gonna play for
one minute with no spam over here below
my people who i have chosen go why is
this but I've you guys played star wall
yeah it's a I think it said of the UK
and pretty sure say on that handle it's
basically a multiplayer game where
you're all narwhals and you have to stop
the narwhal in Narwhal heart yeah it's
pretty good pick different colors put
something on your head tell me what your
name is my name's Tim Tim vs Doug Doug
Doug and Tim timber and with claws the
dog a tip all right the tool for the
PlayStation Vita begins now press the a
button please aaron ross the tip all
that is required is the tip to pierce
the heart the buttons are as follows a
is to flap your tail use the ant left
analog stick to point yourself in a
different
got our first hit of the round there's
44 seconds left one nil is the score
these graceful athletes are tomorrow
what a face from Doug Tim and Doug here
locked in a death struggle for a
playstation vita the hard expose that's
amateur mistake you can't be that
careless with your heart we've got 12 20
lemons equalized we're counting down to
15 will be a flop it gets it on the
wrong side and nine a lady's got through
it's too we're counting on one and here
he is folks let's go look at PETA show
photos Oh go go go go
hello oh yeah your runner-up wearer of
the guy who almost got to win thanks so
much for playing guys all right I think
we gotta get our asses out of here
because there's another panel on again
thank you to all of our guests who came
on the show Pete Hines earlier as well
and later Bella and Chris with the
surname which is really hard to finance
and he said again you're asking he tries
to thank you very much and bathroom in
the lobby this week if you're watching
this on Tuesday and I have enjoyed the
future I hope it's great Tuesday at two
p.m. pacific the lobby every single week
that's true it is on that time and also
you can just watch it on the man because
it's the internet you know whatever and
like very much for hanging our folks and
yeah we'll see you next PAX East I guess
you